Deadpool 2 was filled of twists and
surprises by the unexpected demise of
the entire x-force team but maybe the
biggest shock of all was the reveal of
the biggest bad guy of them all the
juggernaut so how did Ryan Reynolds and
company managed to keep juggernauts a
surprise for so long and how exactly did
they make juggernauts at all here's a
look at some surprising secrets the
biggest fans may not know about
juggernaut in Deadpool 2 top secret
project Deadpool 2 kept a lot of its
biggest jokes a secret like the
unexpected cameos of superstars Brad
Pitt and Matt Damon and keeping spoilers
off the internet was no easy task as
writer and executive producer Paul
Wernick revealed in the special features
on Deadpool twos home release sometimes
the secrecy thing gets ridiculous you
know our sides came in red because
apparently you can't photocopy red and
then she shreds them it's like working
in the CIA sometimes but the biggest
source of leaks turned out to be
incredibly random as juggernaut surprise
appearance was almost spoiled by another
surprise appearance when legendary Guns
N Roses guitarist Slash turned up on set
Reynolds said it was a security
nightmare suddenly all these pictures of
slash were on people's phones with like
juggernaut in the background unless
they're like no guys you can't post any
those you know or at least Photoshop the
crap out of them the blob even though
juggernaut was created using CGI the
actors on the set still needed a
reference to play off during filming the
solution a giant padded dummy that
helped the actors they all their
performances but it also led to even
more problems keeping the juggernauts
appearance secret as rights are very 16
and if you've seen the physical
conference it is definitely juggernaut
it's like his outline you can see their
helmet and then
below I'm it's just this kind of
amorphous blob the big problem that
signature helmet which couldn't belong
to anyone else at anyone who has any
background in comics if they were on set
that day would spy that particular get
up and go hot jaggernots gonna be in the
movie the man in the iron mask since an
amorphous blob when the pin particularly
scary for audiences no offense to fans
of the blob the folks behind Deadpool
decided to use CGI to animate Javon or
and when we say the folks behind
Deadpool we mean the role was actually
played by a team of director David Leach
and Ryan Reynolds himself yep it's true
Reynolds provided the voice under the
motion capture for the body or leached
it the motion capture for the
juggernauts facial expressions and the
reason was simple it was just more
efficient to do it themselves rather
than waste time bringing another actor
up to speed on the role he's definitely
a mash up of us and that's really born
out of the need to work efficiently sir
a weird amalgamation using craft teams
of renderers are the guys that like free
of life that one took a village sells
all of us for jumping in and go hugger
black bomber Dzhokhar North's appearance
in the movie was also nearly revealed
thanks to the casting of a completely
different character Jack Cassey is black
Tom Cassidy in the comics of course
black Tom and juggernauts of partners so
in order to keep the secret fox decided
to use a different code name when making
the casting announcements and
fortunately according to Wernick that
didn't quite work it was released that
Jack was playing with that he was black
Bob which was a terrible idea that you
know they could have come up with
something else other than black blank
like couldn't have been like Larry as it
turns out black Tom barely even appeared
in that port Oh meaning this secret
ultimately almost leaked on his behalf
and their real reason whoops the
irresistible force during the film's
climax that juggernaut was seemingly
stopped for good when the good guys
stuck an electrical cord into the wrong
soccer
well before you get too weepy for poor
ol jugs though take heart as eagle-eyed
fans notice that in the film's final
scene juggernaut appears to be alive
after all so what does this mean for
juggernaut future nobody knows for sure
but chances are we haven't seen the last
of him after all that's pretty hard to
stop a juggernaut
[Music]